viewed from above some parts of Lake
Constance look more like a river the
lake has a surface area of 536 square
kilometers the borders of Germany
Austria and Switzerland meet here
german photographer aki minda travels
all over the world to capture images of
landscapes but Lake Constance has been
his chosen home and favorite motif for
the past 11 years he has shot tens of
thousands of photos in this region and
published them in coffee table books and
periodicals Fabregas a boarding for me
Lake Constance is the ideal habitat it's
a great landscape and cultural space for
me as a photographer it's paradise not
just because I find motifs everywhere
whether it's a baroque church and beer
now or the view over the lake or the
alpenglow in the evening the light
simply changes it every time of year and
every time of day I can't see enough of
it oh and um come here gani thoughts in
the state Nicholas Church in
Friedrichshafen is one of the city's
main landmarks this German city is the
second largest on Lake Constance is
shores about 58,000 people live here
not to be missed is the former Harbor
train station the first train station on
the lakes Shore the Zeppelin museum has
been housed here since 1996 the world's
largest collection of materials and
airships shows the technical details and
history of sep lens the airships were
named for their builder count ferdinand
zeppelin at the beginning of the 20th
century he brought the production site
to produce often a partial
reconstruction of the LZ 129 Hindenburg
shows what travelling in a Zeppelin was
like absolutely Stephanie said these
fredericks often is certainly the city
of Zeppelin Staal of kisses where most
of the world's famous airships were
built ill and it's where the myth lives
on today ruthlessly along with the
Industrial Development that Count von
Zeppelin launched back then so as that
is still in effect today look some
reason back to the shore of Lake
Constance which is best explored by boat
this ferry for example flies back and
forth between the German cities of mares
Borg and Constance
Lake Constance is also a popular
destination for water sports fans
especially in the summer
but active vacationers will also find
plenty to do here in the winter for
example stand-up paddling which involves
standing on a surfboard the Polynesian
sport can be practiced year round on the
rather placid lake constance stand-up
paddling is relatively easy to learn and
it's supposed to be good for you Roger
Gillett strengthens the back muscles in
particular these twisting motions and
this pushing motion strengthen the
muscles around the spine muscles you
don't otherwise use many people today
sit all day in the office remnants of
ancient settlements can be found all
around the lake it looks like a
lakeshore view was appreciated even
thousands of years ago reconstructions
at the lake dwelling museum in inter
olden show what these homes on stilts
may have looked like in 2011 unesco
declared these buildings a world
cultural heritage site some saunas at
the mayor's Berg hot springs are also on
stilts just a few kilometers from the
open-air archaeological museum in winter
this is the perfect place to recharge
your batteries after sweating you take
the plunge into water measuring 4
degrees Celsius look I can't see enough
of it you never get sick of it
everyone's eye out for me feel of Lake
Constance because you can really use it
and also it's simply a stunning view
Chelsea
a trip to Lake Constance pays off any
time of the year
you